hi everyone
uh welcome to the
mapping as knowing a lecture series of
the frankie program
in science and the humanities at yale i
am delighted to um introduce our speaker
this evening
um it's a science fiction writer kim
stanley robinson
who uh will be talking to us about
mapping the future of the anthropocene
so first i want to i see richard and
barbara frankie there
signed in to our zoom universe
so i wanted to thank both of them for
their generosity
in endowing the frankie program that is
um
allowing us to host these wonderful
events so so thank you
uh richard and barbara and welcome
and i also want to remind everyone uh
who has signed in that we are recording
this so could you
kindly um turn off your videos
um and mute your microphones for now
and the format that we are planning to
have for this evening
is that stan will be speaking for about
40 45 minutes
and we will take questions afterward
so kindly type in your questions on the
chat
and ty um dr cam
hey tai hello she will be managing the
chat and you know i also want to give a
big shout out to tai
without whose help we will not be able
to run this program
as smoothly and um so very grateful tai
for your help
uh with this so um without further ado
let me introduce i don't quite know
where to start
so first i have to control my gushiness
a little bit because i am a really
ardent fan
of stan and stan's writing
so stan as you all know is um
one of the foremost um
writers of um the science fiction genre
and he began publishing novels um in
1984
and you know his work has been described
as
humanist science fiction literary
science fiction
so in a way he crosses genres although
one could one could fairly comfortably
say that
what he really envisions and imagines
are views of the future but infused with
an emotional psychological and human
touch so it's not just about
robots and automation um so he
um is a very proud defender and advocate
of the genre of science fiction and he
actually regards and i think me and many
other fans around the world
concur that it's one of the most
powerful of all literary forms because
it allows us to imagine futures
futures that we all dream about and
futures that we sometimes
are scared of as well so he was
born in illinois but moved to california
uh when he was very young and he has
remained a loyal californian
he um you know he has often talked about
um i want to give you a bit of a feel
for him because this is one of the
things about
zoom because you can't see the person in
the flesh
so i want to give you a little more sort
of biographical information
so that you can kind of imagine what
must be influencing
the way in which he thinks and sees the
world so he grew up
playing in orange groves uh stretching
out for miles
and you know in a very suburban part of
california that over his lifetime
fundamentally transformed and
um and you know with um with encroaching
uh urbanism and modern life kind of
entering um
closer and closer in and changing sort
of the
environment around him so he was a very
sensitive to that
and i mentioned this because many of you
who read
him will see that this attunement to
nature
and to the attunement to how humans have
been transforming
nature is a very fundamental theme that
runs through
many of his books so he actually
stumbled
upon science fiction um late uh
relatively speaking while he was in
college
and then it made such a strong
impression that he knew
immediately that he was really committed
to becoming a writer and that was the
genre
that he would uh really pick for himself
so he enrolled at university of
california at san diego
in and received his ba in literature and
um and he started at that time already
he had developed the idea of writing a
trio of books exploring
three different alternative histories in
which southern california had gone down
different paths and this
has this is the famous orange county
trilogy
then he briefly left california and came
eastward
to boston university and did an m.a in
english and then went back to ucsd to
finish
a phd so he finished his phd
in 1982 and a revised version of his phd
was what was published in 84 as the
novels of philip k
dick so after publishing these few uh
novels um stan moved with his wife
who is an environmental toxicologist and
a renowned chemist
and they moved to switzerland where they
lived for a few years and then
he began at that point to write full
time then they came back to washington
dc
but you know eventually they just moved
back to california and he lives
still in um davis um since
i think since 1991 right you've been in
davis
and they actually live uh with his
wife and son they live um in village
homes which is sort of a planned
community
that shares many things in common with
the community that he depicts in his
1990 novel pacific edge
and so he is actually a very proud
stay-at-home parent
which gives him a lot of time to write
and think
and his wife whose career he is
supported
works full-time as a chemist and um
you know many of you have likely read
you know
his aurora the mars trilogy i mean i
don't know where to start and you know
and he has so many awards and
recognition
that i'm not going to take more any more
time from his talk today
to uh to mention them so
what can i say i'm personally an ardent
fan of stan's and as a scientist and an
astr
and as an astrophysicist i'm very
finicky about the sci-fi that i read
and love i find that it's often very
hard to get that needed distance to
derive pleasure from the writing as one
is always apt to interrogate the science
all the time and so stan's writing is
one that i have had
no trouble with at all and his books
have been
singular as while they don't always
necessarily take me where i
intended to go i have always ended up
where i needed to be so i would like to
turn it over to stan and we really look
forward to
and thank you so much for agreeing to
speak and we look forward to
hearing you well thank you very much for
that kind introduction priya
and thank you tai and um and the francas
and yale it's a real pleasure and i hope
that we
also get to do this in person someday um
post vaccine in a in a more mobile
and social time i really look forward to
that
and yes today i i'm going to talk about
mapping the anthropocene
and it's an interesting assignment kind
of given me by
yale and by this speaking series and
allowed me to think about it in
ways that i quite enjoyed is uh
if you talk about mapping the future
then you are necessarily talking about
cognitive mapping
so that's really the framework for
everything that follows and so else
as i as priya said i'll speak for about
40 to 45 minutes and then hope to
engage with questions as well so
cognitive mapping this is a phrase that
my teacher
frederick jameson who also taught at
yale for a couple years
uh uh brings forth us it's somewhat like
weather forecasting or a modeling
exercise or scenario building
trajectory following you see it a lot in
the sciences and
um and it is and and everywhere else and
it's necessarily
ideological and i mean that in the best
sense because i take ideology to mean
an imaginary relationship to the real
situation
i like this definition a lot because um
there is a real situation
out there but our knowledge of it has to
be
imaginary and by which i mean selective
partial and shaped by our prior
assumptions so that we see some
evidence better than others based on our
axioms
and so maps become a kind of an analogy
for this process
and maps too are ideological uh and and
by analogy think of the mercator
projection
where uh greenland is as large as north
america
and novia zemlia is as large as
australia
this is a distortion that is made by
some axioms that you use to put the
globe onto a flat
surface now you can try to adjust for
that and
this is exactly what ideological work
would can be conceptualized as
um you can make adjustments to keep the
continents sized accurately to the way
that they are in the real world you have
to cut
the globe apart and spread out your map
in a kind of transverse directions
a kind of a giant triangle
on a wall and this you get a different
distortion which is that the um the
oceans are
erased and uh antarctica doesn't get
included very well
so in the end you might even want um a
globe instead of a map
and of course this is another kind of
map but it's cast on to the same
shape as the thing it's trying to
represent and this might be an
interesting way to think of
can you adjust your ideology to get a
better view
of what you're looking at and also
if you're mapping the anthropocene
you're mapping the future you're mapping
time rather than space
and here it gets incredibly complicated
because
um what unit of time is relevant
there's there's actually this would be
something to talk with uh priya about in
more detail but it seems to me that i
hear that in subatomic physics there is
indeed a minimum
unit of time that you can't go
below because there is um
uh i think it's the pauli exclusion um
principle that objects can't occupy the
same space and then the speed of light
crossing that space gets you to
something like 10 to the negative
34th of a second that's a pretty short
minimum
but you can't go smaller without
breaking the laws of physics
and then at the other end you have
eternity or maybe the age of the
universe 13.82 billion years is the
latest estimates of astrophysicists and
i
i love that too at the end of the 0.82
that's pretty precise considering the
question involves but in between that
if you're trying to map the future what
what do you do
um and and can you look at your
assumptions in a way that
for instance going back to maps of the
world that puts
south at the top and i think that's a
good
thing to keep in mind that there's
probably assumptions that we're making
that we seldom uh interrogate or think
about why is north always at the top of
the map and south of the bottom when you
reverse it it looks weird and wrong but
maybe you need to do that to realize
that it's arbitrary and
sort of axiomatic so
let's think about the anthropocene
what is it well it's another cognitive
mapping and it's and it's
of splitting up time into units some
unit between the minimum
and eternity and this is uh what
historians would call periodization
and again my teacher fred jameson um we
cannot
not periodize in other words you can
never look at history
and say well it's just one uninterrupted
flow from the beginning of the universe
till right now and you just take it one
second at a time
we don't do that we periodize and each
system
of periodization reveals a theory of
history
that is making the cuts so you can
simply do it numerically
there's the 16th century the 17th
century the 18th century the 19th
century
numerical and it's simple in that regard
but that's still periodizing then in
each century you think something
different is going on
there's systems of power imperial
systems like the chinese dynasties
that's how they periodize chinese
history sometimes
or empire names the roman empire the
persian empire
and so on there's the technological
so you have the paleolithic followed by
the agricultural revolution the
industrial
revolution the steam era coal era
the electronic era the nuclear era the
digital era these are all technological
periodizations
and then you have the cultural it's so
middle
ages the renaissance the enlightenment
the the modern period
the postmodern period which we were in
until this word anthropocene got
invented but nobody was particularly
happy because what comes after
post-modernism you would have to have
post-post-modernism and it was clearly a
provisional name
but something was changing in modernism
that hadn't yet been
uh properly theorized so it was a tag
name that started in the mid-80s again
with jameson's strong support and now
i think has been superseded by the name
anthropocene but we'll talk about that
and then lastly there's the geological
okay
the fossil record gives us a way of
interpreting the past of the earth
such that there are break points along
the way and names that go along with
them and this is really
complicated there's actually a
stratigraphy committee
the american geophysical union and
geologists in general have
parsed the past very finely in different
formats of changes
but let's just think about the triassic
the jurassic the cretaceous
and then after the cretaceous which
ended 65 million years ago which with
what we now
consider to probably be a meteor impact
at the kt
boundary um uh a subsequent
post-cretaceous also divided into
periods that eventually ended up in the
holocene
which was where we've been since the end
of the last ice age about 11
000 years ago okay and all of that
the anthropocene is a word invented by a
eugene sturmer
in the 1980s and it was picked up by
um scientist paul crewson in
2000 or 2002 he was using this
periodization politically and this is so
often the case
in order to emphasize the danger of
human impacts on earth's
biosystem and the there was the uh
he was trying to make the point that
humanity had become the largest
force in the critical zone from the top
of the atmosphere to the bottom of
the bed to bedrock the the lifestone you
might say the biosphere itself that
that humans were the largest force
entrance
in transforming that zone quickly and
mostly in a bad way and that was why you
would call it the anthropocene
and this definition is therefore a
combination
of the geological kind of
cut the human various cuts that
sometimes get called big history so that
you include the planet
um but also the other ones culturally
and all other periodization schemes have
collided
in this term the anthropocene to give it
a particular power
and suggestiveness to the to
uh our reckoning of where we are now in
history
um now i want to note on the side that
the anthropocene as such
as a definition is a kind of a science
fiction story
if you imagine that 25 million years in
the future
aliens come to earth alien geologists or
scientists or or some post-human version
of us
come back to earth or whatever and they
look at it and they study its geological
record
they will be able to see a change point
like the kt boundary
that marks where humans began to
intervene
so uh intensively that it could be seen
25 million years later in the geological
record of just the rocks
well that's uh a provocation
immediately a people ask well what
marker are you talking about
i think this question is not so
interesting because um
if you add up all the markers it will be
undeniably the case
it could be the rapid shift in co2
levels although
the aliens might say well something
happened
naturally it could be the sudden
appearance of radioactive elements in
the surface
from our atomic explosions could be a
layer of plastics and microplastics
although
will those last 25 million years etc etc
the anthropocene as where it started has
become a kind of minor academic
argument or game that people play to
make various points about the impacts of
humans
when europeans arrived in new world
their diseases and their
genocide killed off the local
populations to the point that the
areas of land that had been being kept
clear by new world
native american populations uh
reforested so quickly that there was a
drop in the co2 level in the atmosphere
at that time
etc let's say that probably
the atomic explosions will serve like
the iridium layer at the kt boundary
that it's weird and there's no other
good explanation so that
um the anthropocene is probably real now
another game in academia immediately cam
came into play maybe it's not humanity's
impact
the anthropocene maybe it's the way
we've been exploiting the earth and
other people
that has made an irrevocable mark in the
geological record and so it's been
called
provisionally the capital ocean uh
suggesting that it wasn't people but
capitalism that left the big marks in
the geological record
but now this is another kind of science
fiction called the alternative history
um in other words you have to uh you're
implying that if there had been a
different
social organization for humans since the
uh 16th century since modernization
that that would have not left the same
kind of mark on the earth
you could you know you imagine a
sociology
or a medicine ocean or a science ocean
or a utopia ocean in which um
the geological mark wouldn't be clear
because we had done such a good
good job of matching our
activities to the biosphere's capacities
well
i think this is very unlikely an
alternative history is weak
precisely because you can't test it it's
just an assertion
but also and and therefore it's
impossible to prove
and so i think it's best to stick to the
anthropocene
as the name for this that i think can be
defended as a real mark in geological
history
so what does it imply because i want to
say immediately
and this is fundamental to mapping the
anthropocene
the humanities impact on the biosphere
is not necessarily the equivalent of
saying
disaster of saying mass extinction event
and
total disruption in other words
there could be a good anthropocene the
anthropocene could be
a good one or it could be a bad one and
that's the first part of our mapping
the first map of the anthropocene looks
like
a a sort of a a perfect spread out
a a blunderbuss you might say from one
point
with a trajectory shooting off in all
directions from
a really horrific catastrophe of a mass
extinction event that would
hammer humanity as well so
but i what i want to say is that this
spread of possibilities right now which
is
disorienting and that's a good word to
use when you're talking about maps
if the future that we're facing could be
anything from a horrific mass extinction
event
that wrecks human civilization and
leaves us in some kind of
post-apocalyptic dystopia
and yet on the other hand it could also
be a progressively better adjustment to
the biospheric limits and to
technologies and to social systems such
that we get to a prosperous age i don't
want to say utopia i
don't want to say golden age i just want
to say it could get really good
so um that being the case
it's so confusing but what i want to
suggest is that from this point
if things begin to degrade and we don't
address our problems right away
then what you get to is a kind of a um
you begin to slide off into bad futures
that are harder and harder to deal with
if we deal with our problems now and
begin to improve our systems
and get a handle on our problems then
things begin to get better and better in
ways that will be robust
and what i want to suggest is it's the
middle that is excluded in a kind of an
aristotelian way um the future is
where it's as if we're walking down a
peninsula
um and this peninsula is uh
sharp on both directions going downhill
and we're and the peninsula is also
attenuating in getting more and more
narrow where choices have to be made
this is a kind of a backpackers
uh a rambler in the sierras type image
but i bring it up because i want to
suggest that
the the moves we make now will be
determinative for the next three or four
generations of how desperate
if we were to go down the bad side how
desperate it would be for them to crawl
back over the ridge onto the good side
whereas right now
it would be less difficult to do it now
this map of the the ridge edge
dropping to bed or good is actually uh
topologically exactly the reverse of
some maps i've seen
of our possibilities right now and these
are also
valuable so um these are all thought
exercises
the i'm thinking of a paper in the
national academy of the sciences that
has
the future as a kind of a big valley
going downhill around u-shaped
valley-like in a glacial area
where almost all the futures lead to
temperatures that are too
high and then if we do a certain number
of things correctly
um you could go up and sideways
into a zone of safety and so again it's
topological
or topographical and it's imagery it's
like a map
and it's the opposite of the map i just
suggested and
yet it probably speaks to something real
that is maybe focused
in particular on our co2 use so it's not
wrong but
but these are three different maps right
in a row the blunderbuss
of the future could be anything from
terrible to great
the uh ridge going downhill suggesting
that um
we we'd best get it right now
um in order to make things better for
pre following generations and then
also the big valley drop which also
suggests that that side canyon
is coming up quickly that gets us off
into a safe future
so now for the rest of the talk here i
am going to ignore
the ba uh describing the bad
anthropocene because i think it's just
too obvious
essentially the name for it could be the
mass extinction event that we're heading
into
and a mass extinction event could lead
to crop failures which would lead to
food shortages for humans it also could
lead to rises in temperatures to where
you get up into the wet bulb 35 zone
which is that zone of heat and humidity
in combination
that would lead to human deaths
without air conditioning in other words
overwhelming the human body's ability to
uh regulate its temperatures sweating
doesn't work in the high
humidity the heat gets high enough the
combination of the two is a kind of heat
index
wet bulb 35 is a fatal to human beings
and
it could be only 95 degrees in terms of
heat
but if that 95 degrees is combined with
super high humidity it becomes fatal
and so civilization would be hammered
in a bad anthropocene and um
that would mean that although it pro
humans probably wouldn't go extinct
because of a certain
um clever resilience that we have and
there's so many of us that with the help
of our
social organization and technology and
hanging in there
you could it isn't really right to talk
about
extinction but it would certainly be a
post-traumatic time like oh my gosh
in generations past we screwed up so
badly that we don't have any federal
animals and we're only one-tenth of
population we were
um it would be a dark ages followed by a
post-traumatic and dysfunctional
human time that really uh
almost would be it would make the dark
ages after the roman empire
look like almost nothing really
it would be way way way way worse so
let's leave that on the side
what would a good anthropocene look like
and how do we get there
so um good anthropocene let's think
about that
what it would look like i think is very
simple first of all in a negative sense
no mass extinction event we would have
dodged the mass extinction event and the
other
animals would still and plants that are
all endangered
would still be with us in a viable
biosphere now that's
a minimum but it's very important
because the only unfixable thing
in our biosphere with the resilience and
robustness of life is extinction
don't be fooled by this science fiction
trope of de-extinction
um it's interesting to try it and it
might even work for a couple
of targeted species it's a nice thought
experiment but it
isn't a solution it won't work for the
most of the extinctions that will happen
so we need to dodge a mass extinction
event that's
the minimum then also we have to think
about people it's our species we're in
the anthropocene what do humans do
you would want to postulate that there's
enough food water shelter clothing
healthcare education
work and security safety and peace for
everybody
adequacy for everybody nobody
immiserated
that would be another um benchmark of a
good anthropocene
and you can also just call that justice
so the
a good anthropocene there would be
justice and then also
in balance with the biosphere's energy
flows and with its ability to
um process our wastes and our pollution
these are two very important uh flow
questions
that not only would humans would be
imbalanced with its biosphere but the
immediate implication of that would be
that all the rest of the living world
would also
be adequacy and okay so let's just say
10 billion people and hope that that's a
maximum and it seems quite likely
actually
and all of them with enough and all of
the rest of
the living world has enough also
now can this be done physically
in terms of energy flows yes
um we have the physical capability and
the technological capability
of achieving that which is good news i
think and it comes out of an
assessment of the scientific uh
communities
investigations it's only possible to get
to that
if that becomes humanity's project
we won't clutch to it we won't get there
accidentally
and we won't get there if we pursue
humanity's project right now
which is the creation of profit in the
capitalist system
that's an index that is
putting together any number of factors
to make a number that accrues value
to um a small percentage of the world's
population in a power system
this is what capitalism is but the index
of profit
is is faked on any number of levels
and it ends up being a kind of a ponzi
scheme a multi-generational ponzi scheme
so this is another way to map the future
systematically stealing in a kleptocracy
from the generations to come as well as
the rest of the life world
so if we were going to get to a good
anthropocene
we would have to change the political
economy that we live in that we now
call neo-liberal late capitalism the
the system of laws that runs the world
right now in all of our activities in an
over-determining way and even science
itself has to get funded
this world is set up with um
goals and rewards that are
destroying the the biosphere
and also wrecking human lives this is
the sad news
the bad news it's as obvious as heck
though
there's no reason for me to insist on it
because if it weren't true then why
would we be in the world that we're in
and of course there have been
improvements there has been poverty
reduction there are good things
happening
they all happen as a gift economy on
this side
none of them have been profitable un's
millennial project of 2000 to lift
the poorest and most immiserated people
on the planet up into adequacy
that's been achieved and it wasn't even
that costly but it wasn't profitable and
it was done on the side
outside the rule of profit and that's
interesting
because if we could do that on the
margin what could we do
if it was actually the whole point of
civilization's efforts
so um i'm going to go briefly through
some other points in a good anthropocene
one of the necessary i mean it wouldn't
be sufficient but it's necessary is to
decarbonize fast and maybe even get into
carbon drawdown out of the atmosphere
so okay on the technological level we
have the means to create
a steady-state uh balance with the
biosphere but we're not there yet
we've invented it but we haven't applied
it and right now the burning of fossil
fuels
is a major impact on the environment
it'd be best to get back to 350 parts
per million of co2 in the atmosphere
and there are various means to do that
both technological and biological
it maybe could be done but it would be a
very big expensive project it would have
to be the goal of civilization and maybe
it should be
so here's another map for you
we can afford to burn like 500 gigatons
more of fossil fuel into the atmosphere
before we would hit
that two degrees celsius rise
in average global temperature that has
been identified as the maximum we can
get without horrific results
500 gigatons is 500 billion tons of
carbon burned into the atmosphere
at the rate we're going that's about 15
more years
but listen to this about 3
500 gigatons of fossil carbon have been
identified
and located by
geologists and by scientists around the
world
and this 3500 gigatons of carbon
about 70 percent of that is owned by
nation states and about 30 percent by
private
corporations that 3 500
gigatons of fossil carbon 3000
gigatons needs to stay in the ground and
never be burned into the atmosphere but
it's already on the books as assets for
the private companies
and it's already in the national uh uh
imaginary of the countries involved that
have the most
parts of this as as a national security
issue that in other words many uh
national economies depend on selling and
burning that fossil carbon to support
everything else that they do for their
people
now every one of these nation states has
signed the paris agreement
and has agreed to stay below two degrees
the implications of that create a
logical contradiction
in that many countries rely on selling
and burning precisely the carbon that
they've also promised not to sell and
burn
and i'm not just talking about saudi
arabia although they are
big amongst them but also russia the
united states of course
canada australia venezuela brazil mexico
south africa it goes on and on in china
and india it goes on and on that these
fossil fuel assets for these countries
are on the books and the politicians are
thinking to themselves
we'll just burn what we can get away
with before this becomes a stranded
asset
there will be uh social forces trying
their hardest to burn the whole 3500
gigatons and because the value of those
3 000
that shouldn't be burned if you were to
make a
completely artificial exercise um
would be approximately you know some i i
costed it once
when the price of oil was a little
higher than it is now at something like
1
600 trillion dollars and people are
going to want
that money so here's an interesting map
there should be a world map that shows
where all this fossil carbon is you
could easily
uh coal oil natural gas where are these
deposit
who owns them how much is it worth
and how do we compensate these nations
and companies although i think all this
stuff should be nationalized immediately
there's no private company that should
be in in charge of fossil fuels
how do we um
compensate for the loss of that money
because um each country's burn can be
tracked and
back in time as well it can be tracked
historically right up
and and it's present burned both can be
tracked and here's a rough cut
if we can burn 500 out of 3500
possibly every country should only be
able to burn
one-seventh of what they own and then
the rest
uh they get paid for in uh for keeping
in the ground
in an amortized discounted and overtime
way
because it would have taken a couple
centuries to burn all that
and in other words there is a financial
aspect
to the good anthropocene that is crucial
to think about
i want to come back to that before i end
but i see i have time for just a couple
more points
still thinking about the good
anthropocene we need
um perhaps something like eo wilson's
half earth
a principle which sounded so radical
when he thought of it that 50 percent of
the earth should be left to the animals
to the wild creatures and we should keep
our activities to the other 50 percent
that's most useful to us
this sounded like a a a very
old and distinguished scientist going
emeritus and
suggesting something completely utopian
and crazy and then five years later
european union and other nation-state
groups are proposing 30 percent of the
land to be left to the animals
it's amazing how quick that came about
and the y2y
yukon to yellowstone habitat corridor is
one indication that these
wild zones be connected up with each
other all over the earth
humans congregate more in cities and
then there's a carbon drawdown to
rewilding
as well as a dodging of the mass
extinction event which i claim is a
fundamental to the whole project
that leads to of course agriculture we
got to feed ourselves
and it interesting to contemplate can
agriculture become a carbon neutral or
even a carbon negative
activity a growing of crops
ranching aquaculture it's said that an
acre of ocean water in the shallows
where
kelp beds and seagrass can grow that
that
acre of a shallow ocean water can hold
five times more carbon than an
equivalent acre of land anywhere
um indeed carbon neutral agriculture and
food production in general
is going to be on the table as the
technological work of the good
anthropocene
very briefly i want to mention
geoengineering
but only because then the word
has become reified by which i mean it's
turned into a thing and nobody uh
discusses
it what it now really means in popular
parliaments especially on the left where
i
live um privileged white male elite
imposing a supposed silver bullet techno
solution that will
save their way of life but probably
backfire and make things worse for
everyone else
that's geoengineering well define it
that way and indeed
bad idea but um if you think of
large-scale
interventions in the biosphere hoping to
reduce the damage
of a global temperature rise as being a
definition such that
women's rights are geo engineering for
the good uh gardening
is geoengineering for the good anything
we do at global scale
that has impacts because there are so
many humans as small as they might be
individually
if they scale up you could think of that
as
geoengineering and then if you get to
the
famous case of solar radiation
management can we
imitate pinatubo and throw dust into the
atmosphere
sulfur dioxide whatever to bounce some
sunlight off before it hits earth
that would lower temperature and it
might only last five years and the
repercussions might not be as
uh significant i mean who can tell
but uh if we get desperate in the 21st
century there may be certain nation
states that are
whose people are dying from heat waves
who may do this and the rest of the
world
having burned the carbon especially the
developed world in the north
will have no moral standing to objecting
to jail engineering just for an idea
so um it's an emergency
it's like it would be like pulling the
emergency alarm and pulling out the fire
extinguisher
in a good anthropocene so let's let me
end by talking
going back to this matter of finance
what is money well it's not as easy as
you might think it's a
medium of exchange it's a store place of
value it's a
a demonstration of social trust
so um if you're going to do
the good work of saving the biosphere
and creating a good anthropocene
you need to be able to make a living at
it making a living is not the same as
making a profit where you extract value
and
hoard it to yourself and become richer
than everybody else
there's really good work on what finance
is and its relationship to the state
and the nation-state system and finance
which is to say money the world of
finance are
co-dependents and they're interdependent
people like lazarado say that finance
controls the state people
like joseph vogel and others say that
the two are
hand in hand but those two hands are arm
wrestling for
control i think that's a good image for
it
but in any case when finances is in
control of the state you get neo-liberal
capitalism in the bad point they're at
now
that doesn't work and we've seen 40
years of it
misfiring despite various
improvements on other levels so the good
anthropocene will require
state controlling finance and if the
state is
of the people by the people for the
people in some formulation where you
have good
good political representation as a
citizen and your governments are
essentially your organizations like a
business but working for you for the
good of the planet
then state controlling finance is the
natural and proper order because it's
people controlling finance for the good
so what would that kind of finance
resemble well
a job guarantee if the state guarantees
you a job
then unemployment as a problem goes away
but also if that job is a
wage is a salary is a
compensated by um an
adequate life so that you could get a
job from the state that
gave you a living then all private
industry would have to match it
so job guarantee which is a fundamental
to modern monetary theory
is a good idea progressive taxation that
actually creates
a ratio of if if the people
making the most on the planet were at
adequacy
and the people that the least were made
at adequacy and the people at the most
were making
10 times that a one to ten ratio in um
wage parity it's sometimes called uh
what if you've got true adequacy then
ten times that is stupendous luxury
but the world that we're in it's really
a ratio of
one being grossly inadequate and then
the wealthiest are like 500 times that
or 1500 times that
it's ludicrous and it could be
legislated out of existence by taxation
then also paying off the oil companies
or the nations
really that own the the um
the fossil fuels is part of it and how
can we do that well
money is created by the central bank so
here i'm not talking about speculative
bubble
uh silliness like bitcoin
which is really just a scam i'm talking
about fiat money
made by senior edge by the powers that
be states backed by armies and by their
people
that's what real money is and if real
money is made
to pay first for decarbonization work
for a good anthropocene work and
it only gets paid out for that first
that's a form of quantitative easing we
know quantitative easing works
it it well sort of works but in other
words it goes out there and it doesn't
completely destabilize money as a
concept
in 2008 they made up between five to
eight
trillion dollars and poured into the
system to keep the economy liquid
uh with the pandemic in march they made
up a couple trillion immediately
in order to keep people from starving so
carbon quantitative easing
cqe is an idea that's out there it's a
great idea
you sequester carbon you get a carbon
coin
it has to be defended by the central
banks it has to be made up by the
central banks in concert so that it
isn't just a crypto coin or a
speculative thing that can be
manipulated by by finance it has to be
solidly backed
and then you're at something solid the
civilization
that pays itself to do the right things
and we're not there yet but we have
actually the mechanisms
globalization is not bad because we're
on one planet bad globalization is bad
like the bad anti-scene is bad good
globalization
is uh in fact necessary because it's go
it can't just happen in one country
there is no pocket utopia
it's all or nothing which is frightening
of course
but we're on one planet and we have no
choice in that
so um i am going to
end with that and turn it back over
uh to apria and the rest of you and uh
hope that um that we
survived our hack and maybe that serves
as a model
all the good work that we do that is
going to happen in the face of chaos and
disruption
and hacking and people who don't
share the same ideology and are going to
be trying to mess things up
so um what i describe is the lineaments
of a century-long wicked battle
and all in there thank you so much
um stan um that was wonderful so we'll
open up for questions tai
did you want to get started with um yes
sure so uh a comment perhaps leading to
a question
what would a good anthropocene look like
the problem is more complex somebody
noted the sad fact is that humans have
not learned to be themselves
without being anti-centric so this is
what is fatal for the species
the reason being simple no species
cannot live its life support system
uh and the the person offering this
comment says will be no exception we
cannot conceive of a world in which we
are not the center
your thoughts on that oh sure well i
think that's
right the question is bringing up a
valid point that we need to be
more biocentric we need to go back to
the oldest
religion a kind of gaia religion where
humans understand that they are one node
in a larger network of living beings and
that they
all are part of us i think the news that
50 of the dna inside your body is not
human dna
is a shocking new fact that she has to
change everybody who contemplates it for
a while that you yourself are a forest
or a swamp or a biome of some kind
and everything has to work inside you
for you to stay healthy
and then you're part of a larger system
and everything has to work on that
system
also to stay healthy so with the micro
and the macro
we are interpenetrated with the rest of
the biosphere and that can be a
religious position it has been the past
has to come back
in terms of the question of how it would
look like let's say
cities denser lots of more open land
lots more respect for wild animals
as being our cousins our horizontal
brothers and sisters as john muir once
said
and then go from there it would be a
work in progress and i would agree we're
not there we're too anthropocentric and
it would be nice to
um broaden our perspectives to to
to the to actually uh confront the
reality that we can't
uh go it alone as the uh person
commented
yeah and i think that you know um it
might also be helpful
that every time we as humans have
thought that we are at the center of the
physical universe right we've been
displayed
and hopefully now with the discovery of
all these other exoplanets and
possibilities even with just the
nearby stars harboring other planets
right
i think we need to get sort of a little
bit more humble
about cosmically where we are and maybe
this perspective
will help us become a little less
anthropocentric
but i see that you know there is this
tension between
the um the our
desire to always be focused on ourselves
but i think i really liked your
um point that even what we think as the
boundary of us
is not really uniquely us we have
bits of dna from others and very complex
biome i was curious as we are waiting
to use my prerogative as um
as the organizer to ask you so stan the
good anthropocene
is really what what we want to head
toward but we see a lot of
practical mental psychological other
aside from
nation states and that level of
political uh
disagreement and you know ideological
conflicts
to say nothing of military conflicts at
a personal
psychological emotional level have do
you
have a way of thinking about how we
could all affect that transformation
sort of to build towards that
um that's a hard one um because
different people are in different
uh circumstances such that it's
i think a dangerous or inappropriate to
give advice
my situation as a suburban white man
aging house husband in a
sweet eco village in california
i mean this is an amazingly privileged
position maybe one of the most
privileged in the history of the world
for a person an individual so
i would say take what i have to say with
a grain of salt but
one can drop one's carbon burn
dramatically
and we saw this with a pandemic but you
could do it voluntarily as well
and still have like more fun than you
were before
less crap in your life less
worry and anxiety um walking outdoors
uh just taking a simple walk is actually
more satisfying and restful than almost
any
recreational activity you can name
especially the ones that involve
going somewhere else and using
mechanical means to get you
i don't know i don't want to put down
any particular activities but you know
what i mean
yeah um and then uh if you grow plants
even in pots in your apartment
immediately the first reaction is fear
it's
uh it's a stupendous to technological
feat to keep ourselves fed it's not an
automatic
and so growing plants of vegetables or
even
ornamentals is a huge lesson and a
little tiny bit of carbon draw down
especially with a compost heap but also
psychologically
it reorients you to reality because all
of us i think are doing this and i
i actually i appreciate very much people
coming to hear this talk
um given everybody's zoom and screen
fatigue and
it means a lot to me because i think
that it's a gesture towards yale and
towards
my novels um
but all of us that needs to be
integrated with a
physical life in the stuff that you can
touch with your hands
um and and i think that that is a
reorientation it's a kind of mapping
activity
to go outdoors to sit in a garden to to
meet face to face
at socially distanced levels for
the next year or so but after that to
realize that
talking to somebody over a cup of tea is
is already the most
pleasurable activity that you have and
it's a rather low carbon burn
thanks a few more questions have uh come
up
are there no examples in history from
which we can learn or should we really
look for a clean break
i think one has to be able to learn from
history
um priya mentioned my novel shaman
uh how were humans getting by in the
paleolithic
and um are there things we could learn
from them
i think so even though i often talk
about the paleolithic with good dental
care
in other words the things that we can
learn from the paleolithic is not
the totality of how to live that we are
a technological species and it's
good and so along the way the
medicine is one of the fundamental
technologies
public health is another one these
systems that we have
i think what one wants to do is evaluate
all earlier historical societies for
what was valuable in them even though
they were partially
enacted and pull them out and make them
into a new thing
so i don't believe in a clean break i
don't believe in
future humans that would be radically
distinct from what we've been
all along but there certainly is some uh
distinctions to be made
is it a pandora's box to pay nations and
organizations to
not do something horrible to all of us
is paying them out really the best
practical
solution to keep oil in the ground
uh maybe not um that that
immediately i think to myself that does
sound bad
but um i am thinking about the way that
we
reward ourselves for doing useful things
by way of money
and i'm thinking about uh what they call
climate equity which is written
into the paris agreement that the
the people in the areas of the world
that are going to suffer first from
climate change effects
are precisely the people who have burned
the least amount of carbon
so the paris agreement is a stupendously
strong document on this front because a
certain cadre of diplomats and
philosophers and hard-working activists
made the paris agreement
uh the way it is by writing these things
in with huge arguments
and what what the press agreement says
is there's there's a schedule one
nation's developed world that burned a
lot of carbon that are now rich
there's a developing nation scheduled to
or
that are on the list as a and b that
owe less to the payouts necessary
because they've burned less carbon and
have suffered more in the results
so um it wouldn't be just a case if you
go to russia and say
you've got um a thousand gigatons
of um carbon and therefore we are going
to give you
uh 20 trillion dollars right now that
wouldn't work that would crash the
system
you can pressure and use leverage in the
normal way of diplomacy
and of money in general to um say look
we are going to compensate you but it's
at a discounted rate and you're gonna
have to do the right things in order to
you're gonna have to meet carbon
sequestration scheduling in order to get
the payout but then you do get paid for
doing the virtuous thing
and i i mean this is weirdly economic
speak i believe that economics is too
limited
of a way to talk about this but we
organize
global society by way of economic
considerations and
one part of economics is a real and
genuine social science
trying to find the best way forward the
other part is just an excuse for a power
play of the rich over the poor
you've got to de-strand economics and
get to the part that's useful to us
but isn't some of this what you suggest
you know
still within the framework of
transactional capitalism
i mean it's still very much within that
rubric right so
um i guess parts of that we have to live
with because that's what we're
built on can't fundamentally shake that
apart in one go well not in one go i
like a stepwise
march to a true post capitalism but
given where we are now i would say
anti-austerity keynesianism
social democracies democratic socialism
post-capitalism as a stepwise march
from one legal stage to the next so that
it's
more orderly um hopefully less violent
and more effective so i myself am a
full-on
post-capitalist i would believe in i
think capitalism is just a name for a
power system
but we're in it and certainly money will
still exist certainly capital will still
exist
but what what we pay ourselves to do and
how we
own capital these are the big questions
as you know one american has the carbon
footprint equivalent to 20 bangladeshi
the u.s makes up five percent of the
world's population but using 25 percent
of the world's energy
what do you think of naomi klein's
perspective on anthropocene discourse
that the us has a greater responsibility
in reducing the carbon footprint than
any other country on earth
um i am in solidarity with naomi klein
and i think she's right about that
um and then historically and accurately
you have to immediately pull in
also uh china and the european union
and soon enough india but these are at
differential rates historically
so climate equity climate justice would
require
that the united states leading the way
would make a huge
difference you see small countries
operating
with a stupendous care for their
land and with a very low carbon burn
and this includes developed countries
like
switzerland and developing countries
like cuba
which often rates highest on human
welfare versus carbon burn rubrics
so naomi klein has done stupendous work
for clarifying these issues to a general
audience and i
i hope that her next book is about the
global about international finance
because
although her look her focus on local
resistance and on
regional moves these are all necessary
they're necessary but they're not
sufficient because we're in this
international neoliberal capital system
that will simply extract value from the
top of
even good local work so i think she
knows this already and i
i did an event with her very recently
at rutgers and all i can say is that it
would be great if
her work is as widespread as possible
great so um uh ciao carlo so we have a
question from carlo rovelli he um
says you know everything that you say is
very reasonable and
of course he likes and uh falls on the
same camp
but he says you know what i see missing
is the political side in history
rarely people have collaborated just out
of rational thinking and common good
competition is always dominated unless
imposed by a power
how do we move politically towards
collaboration and
we had a very similar question along the
same lines about
from john peters who said you know
recently our country voted for a
candidate who openly opposed this kind
of thinking
so how do you handle political
roadblocks to the good
anthropocene well uh
for me there are two levels here one is
the discursive battle
in other words it's like this it's
talking about it it's convincing enough
people persuading people
that your ideological explanation for
what's going on in the world
is correct enough to act upon so the
discursive battle is
very very important and then i have to
say
you're only ever going to get a working
majority
at best so you can you have to give up
on the notion
of a consensus or of a huge majority
despite the
the obvious utility of saving the
biosphere
um a lot of people don't see it that way
and
with the most vigorous discursive um
persuasive battle
they're still not going to see it that
way because people love their views and
none of us likes to change our views
so a working majority is 51
like in the general election but then
there's the electoral college i mean a
working majority is sometimes up to 60
percent
before you can actually work like in
certain votes in the u.s senate
and 60 percent a high bar in the current
divisive world i have to say
fossil fuel extractive industries are
pouring
immense amounts of money into
disinformation campaigns and into buying
the votes of
legislatures who are elected on one
platform and then vote on another
and support the continued carbon burn
well this has to be kind of unacceptable
and that's partly the discursive battle
and partly political organizing and
partly
fighting for different laws so the
working majority can change the laws
and then the laws can change the the
structure of feeling
and this and the economic system
together at once
so i don't have any good answers for
this because no one does i mean it's
politics right it's it's ugly it's
um irrational it has to do with
very tribal sensations of us versus them
and it's nice to try to pull away from
that and say but wait everybody's on the
same planet and everybody loves their
children
and there you get back to the discursive
battle well that being the case
can you persuade people that um
decarbonization and
and a new way of living with the
biosphere is just in everybody's best
interests
but i don't i mean i think you can tell
from what i'm saying that this
is a way of saying that there's
there's nothing but continued struggle
biocentric communities are all small
communities
maybe one solution is to have small
local communities and i wonder whether
covet has given us glimmers of what that
might look
and feel like one participant suggests
i wonder about that um and i think
it's a human fact that we uh
like our community um my teacher gary
snyder once talked about community
versus network
so your community are the people that
you see and talk to and
interact with and of course in in the
covid regime this is very weird our
communities have been damaged
your network is everybody that you're
connected with all over the world by
this medium and others
so um at the community level you can
organize your town
you can actually make an impact at the
level of your town to do better on
climate
american towns are trying their best to
confront
this crisis by cutting their carbon burn
at the town level
that is absolutely great and and
something that we need to focus on and
not only that but when you focus on that
you can see results of your work you can
talk to people it's social activity
with some results the international
situation is so
i mean you're one eight billionth of the
power structure of the planet but a lot
of people have more money and therefore
more power than you do
that's so abstract that you it ends up
at the
level of discourse so i would say
essentially that you need it all
and that i end up talking about the
global partly because
well naomi klein and others are great at
talking about the regional
and then everybody is involved with
their own local efforts
um and and i would say that it's
these are all great but that they aren't
sufficient
to complete the deal which is to change
the
rules of international capitalism itself
at the level of treaties at the level of
central banks at the level of money
i bring that into the discourse not
because i think it's the silver bullet
or the total solution
but because i think it is necessary part
of all the rest of the efforts it has to
be integrated
from and it isn't even good to say
bottom to top it has to be integrated
from
local to planetary let's put it that way
so tim asks what can be the role
for higher education in the face of the
kinds of transformations that you are
calling for
well i am interested i'm a i'm an
ex-academic and i'm always involved with
universities
like yale here i do a lot and i'm
thinking talking to young people they
are actually
more flexible in their ideologies and
they're learning to shape their
ideologies and where they're going to
throw their efforts in a career
i think there ought to be a freshman
class that i see very clearly in my mind
i mean i'm talking about the syllabus
and the greetings and that would in
their first
year of college give them a cognitive
mapping
like i just tried here an orientation to
the world this is the world situation
there's a science fiction element to
that that i've been incorporating i i
talk to students who are
let's say they're 20 years old let's say
i'm very
close to 70 years old a half century gap
i i tell them when you're my age it will
be the year 2070
you will be in a completely different
world by necessity because
the way things are going now cannot be
sustained
it will change in their lifetimes so um
higher education
ought to be seized the the professorial
class in the administrations and these
are
actually groups that are at odds with
each other often
the academic senates let's say since
they're still in control of pedagogy
to a certain extent they ought to be
looking at this situation and saying we
need to orient these young people these
and send them out into the world with a
um
a well-organized cognitive map for
figuring out what they're going to do
with their lives without getting scared
without freaking out without
um sending them off into various kinds
of of
doominism like okay the world is so
doomed that i'm just going to go party
well
most young college students are not
going to college in order to take that
attitude
so they are they are well set for an
education that would teach them these
things and get them
oriented to the rest of their lives
so uh then we have a question that is
touches a little bit on the personal
uh in which fulon asks um they're
interested in whether the experience of
having
worked as a house husband has informed
your perspective
do you think a transfer of more power to
women
may radically change our ability towards
the good anthropocene
oh yes definitely so and i want to thank
the questioner for that
um because it's important
when women have their full set of legal
rights
and i'm not talking about reproductive
rights i'm talking about property
education and in general the rights
that they are guaranteed by the u.n
declaration of human rights
the reproduction rate goes down to below
the replacement rate
so replacement rate is 2.1 or 2.2
kids per woman in developed countries
where women
have their rights and are busy with
their lives the replace
the it goes down to about 1.5 to 1.8 per
woman and the population begins to drop
and the pressure on the biosphere goes
away
and then also this brings up all of the
work that mostly women do
that keeps alive the world that then
capitalism
can be a parasite on and make profit
there is no profit without social
reproduction
and that's a word for uncompensated
labor of care
so taking care of the little kids
educating the littlest kids
and nursing and taking care of the
elderly
a lot of this is outside of the economy
and if it were included in the economy
profits would be wiped out so that's on
one of the ways in which profit is a
scam
but also you don't want to economize
care and love so you can't just say okay
i took care of my grandmother pay me 20
for that hour no what you would need is
a political economy
that created the space that people could
have an adequate living and still do the
human work of social reproduction
well in in most of the world women
simply have taken on the burden of doing
both of these things at once and this is
why there's so much pressure on women's
lives is they've got a double job
one to make money in the economy and do
their their
work be to take care of their families
uh both older and younger
uh and maybe even partners and and this
is simply like 20 hours a day
so um yeah um
it is super important to uh support the
women of the world to be a feminist men
need to say oh yeah i'm a feminist but
only in a followers kind of a way not a
leaders kind of way
and also see that the laws have changed
and that the rest of the world i mean
if the united states is the leader and
it's not quite true if scandinavia is a
leader
um in these issues and there are many
places in the world beginning to
emphasize women's rights
then they have to work hard to pull
the rest of the world along in that and
that will really help
biosphere health and human um
welfare yes and and by the way thank you
for that because that really ought to be
an
element of my talk and it often is
so um in the red moon you mentioned the
concept of blockchain democracy
do you want to discuss that in the
context of the future anthropocene
does it have room for that
well i think so let me confess that
blockchain is um
difficult to understand technology and i
don't and it often gets confused with
bitcoin which i quite hate
um but blockchain as a system of
encryption
that is um distributed and solidifies
our information about things so that
there
um it creates a more transparent world
as well as a more secure world
of digital information i can imagine
money being blockchain such that you
can't have tax havens or hidden
criminal money i can imagine democracy
being blockchain such that
um and this is true at town levels in
the united states it's open government
it's illegal to meet in private and then
blockchain would kind of digitalize that
i'm a little confused as to the
utility of blockchain sometimes people
tell me well it's just a buzzword for us
codes that are actually simpler than
that are completely available to us so
why even use that word
and you don't want the repetitiousness
of bitcoin's
creation of value by way of running
computers for zillions of hours to no
purpose
it's something like two percent of the
world's energy is being
burned in order to make bitcoin well
this is just carbon
burn foolishness something like the
economy of uh
czech republic or even israel being
burned for nothing
except for a scam so um i'm not so sure
about blockchain
i would need the digital experts to
weigh in on that
so um there's a comment from yanik
joseph um
how about the need to drastically cut
military budgets
well that would be fantastic especially
yeah the u.s military budget is bigger
than all the rest
of the military budgets combined and the
us has 800 military bases placed around
the world and is a functioning
low-key to functioning empire
and that doesn't work um and
that what i can say about the military
is
um i'm looking at the swiss military in
particular but also
all those militaries that end up being
kind of an emergency rescue services
and in the united states the the u.s
navy
i mean the u.s military burns a
stupendous amount of carbon uselessly
but they're also aware that um
decarbonization is a national
security issue and the navy
has uh you know run a nuclear fleet
without accidents because they don't try
to make a profit from it and safety
comes first
they also have been involved in rescue
operations and it's also true that in
modern warfare
navies are all sunk to the bottom in the
first week of a war
and so they need to be thinking about
rescue and non-military
confrontation and in short
if the world got together on this carbon
coin
if civilization was devoted to trying to
avoid the mass extinction event
then the militaries would end up being
like the ccc
one hopes a place of service and not of
conflict and then their budgets of
course could go way down on the
the high the the extremely expensive
armaments the armament race this is um
this could be brought to the
to an end by mutual agreement and should
be part of the big deal
so um let's close with the final
question which is about a word so i
thought this might be a nice
way so a vibrant biosphere and adequacy
for all along with the global security
that would which would go with that
would be a very charismatic goal could
we have come up
with a better term than just adequacy
would this
be the core of a powerful political
movement
yeah that adequate is not exactly
exciting well
okay here's something that i want you to
contemplate
is it it's an old english saying in
bartlett's quotations it comes on like
page seven or something and it's
anonymous
enough is as good as a feast now
um it was hungry people that brought up
that
that made up that proverb and they knew
what they were talking about because
there were feasts
uh from time to time when the harvests
were good but enough
is as good as a feast the more you think
about that the deeper it goes
so okay enough is is sort of a word like
adequate it's
um but you need the whole phrase enough
is as good as a feast
and indeed a feast being bad for you you
could change the old proverb and say
enough is better than a feast
so the word very often has been
utopia the word has been utopia
now we the same way ideology is what the
other person believes
utopia is the good place that we never
get to that is impossible
so definitions matter um but
i have been working in the utopian
tradition
my whole career with the idea that
um a better world is possible and you
need to describe it first in order to
get to
it so um um i
i'm constantly defending the term
utopian but that
because of the attacks on it which are
political attacks
um what would you say
maybe prosperity um
because enough is a form of prosperity
and or
justice maybe justice is the word
um so these i think are much more
inspiring than
adequacy and i invite i thank the
questioner for pointing that out and
um it is a word game because it's the
discursive battle
so let's think about justice and utopia
yeah
yeah that's great i actually there's one
burning question that i think is so
important that
i'm really tempted um yeah if you don't
mind so there is a view sometimes held
by
indigenous and postcolonial discourse
that the entire discourse of the
anthropocene is
of sort of white panic privileged white
people who for the first time realize
that their ascendancy in life is being
threatened it echoes a bit of what you
said about the stereotype of
geoengineering
can you respond to that uh well i can
see that
um what i would say is that the
anthropocene is a word
thought up by scientists to wave the red
flag
to pull the emergency alarm on the wall
in the hotel
and go off like a fire alarm and shock
everybody
we're in an era where human beings have
a
over determining effect on the biosphere
that can be destructive
and so we're in the business of global
planetary
biospheric management or finessing or
cooperation cooperation management
sounds bad
but cooperation i mean we need to get
along in our biosphere
for the long haul so um
there's been so much argument about what
the anthropocene means
that i think that this also can be
included
um and some people date the anthropocene
to simply the arrival of humans out of
africa
people got to australia and by the use
of fire they
changed the biosphere the biomes of
australia by fire
within a thousand years of arrival
in other words um the whole history of
humanity including
indigenous people has been involved with
um
cooperating with the natural productive
forces of the planet the growth
such that uh the amazon for instance was
a gigantic
park with islands that were islands of
of uh heavily nitrogenated uh highland
um gardens the in other words the native
population of the amazon basin
was in good cooperative
relations with that very
uh vibrant uh and quickly growing
landscape
difficult landscape for humans and yet
humans had it in hand and
were living with it cooperatively for
thousands of years
so um the indigenous ought to always be
remembered
um and uh and they are not distinct from
the anthropocene
and there's there's good reasons for a
white panic i mean
white people are actually a minority in
the world's population and they
had a moment of triumphalism and of
white supremacy in all of the worst kind
of ways and that's going to go away
demographically and politically and
spiritually
um but you know what the to get back i
mean as an
aging white man i can just say it's more
comfortable just to be one of the group
than to be anything special
i guess uh in a cosmic sense right we
are all simultaneously
significant and insignificant so
um anyway stan thank you so much for
this wonderful talk
and for taking the time to answer these
questions
we were absolutely delighted to have you
speak at the frankie program today
thank you my pleasure and i want to say
i will have the
chats forwarded to me so that i can
actually see what people have been
saying i haven't
been looking um in order to focus on the
what we're talking
but i'm interested to read what people
said and i want to thank you priya for
the idea of having me and
and for everybody else involved it's
it's a
a great pleasure thank you very much
and thanks everyone for joining in and
making this a
vibrant event bye and see you all later